Hello Freak bitches.
Like what I take advice on whether or not an episode of game of Thrones is good
from three people I thought were knuckleheads.
Like what if there's like three judges for TV shows?
Like well the game of Thrones finale,
you know,
I gave it an a 100 you know,
let's go to these judges dump.
We decided it gets a 40 no fucking way,
right?
And you go to school the next day like dude,
you hear fucking game of Thrones final got a 40 bro.
He lost it.
Got a little ridiculous at the shut your mouth
is.
Ask a couple questions.
I loved it.
Remember when they first escaped the white walkers?
Didn't like the water,
have something to do with it.
I just got on a boat and it's for some reason they can't get in water,
right?
That's the thing,
Right there ice.
You spoiler alert in the fucking boiler at something.
Don't do something about the water.
They can't hang it.
There was a few holes.
When who the fuck tied those chains around that dragon and dragged it up who
went scuba diving and and tied that dragon up?
You'd probably have to assume who had the wrong.
They're not that strong because those dudes are fucking them up.
They're not that strong.
Who's carrying those gigantic chains down there underwater?
Tie Up the dragon and drag it up.
Who's doing it?
Well,
they're all dead so they probably don't give a shit on the corner.
They couldn't go through the water.
They can't get into water.
He's right.
So how did they do it?
They call the big hole.
I'll accept the drag,
the accepted.
Very good point to drag and I can accept.
That's a very legitimate points when they hit the water that I don't remember.
I don't like water,
but they don't like it.
But to know ties to drag him from getting to ships.
So islands like a keep him from going to an island.
That's why these other guys are like,
fuck this.
I'm going to an island.
I'm going to wait on the iron island.
Right.
Is it possible that just slowing the things down?
They,
they cannot get into water for some reason.
They established that several times and then all of a sudden they cut.
They don't,
they don't show how they tied this Goddamn.
Yeah.
Dragon up with the chain.
It's like one of those chains that you hold navy ships to port,
you know,
and who typed them up?
They just cut to them,
dragging them out.
Watching that dragon get pulled out.
I can suspend a little.
I can,
I can live with the inconsistency of the dead people dragging the dragon out of
the ice water.
I can go want consistency.
I can live with that.
But I'm,
I'm with him.
I didn't even notice that when I watched the show.
I didn't need that.
They went in the water and I love game of Thrones.
Ma'Am.
I haven't missed shut up.
That just got me fucked up.
Yeah,
they fucked up.
It's a big hole.
You're right.
Big.
Hello.
Goddammit.
You're right.
Maybe like in the last,
uh,
episodes,
they'll show how the fuck they tied that dragon up.
Stupid whole.
Yeah.
And did anyone catch it?
Do they say,
fuck it,
let's do it anyway.
What is,
we're led to believe that these,
these different kingdoms like king's landing and all that are like,
like for like countries away.
But man,
they are traveling to damn quick.
They get from one city to the next city there at the wall and then they meet and
at the snow come on in The Bahamas and then the walking over mountains like,
dude,
this can take months.
She said it's almost like,
it's almost like that whole kingdom is like,
like Redondo Beach,
West Hollywood,
north Hollywood,
Compton.
Do you know what I mean?
When you're talking 20 minutes?
Mike Perry was supposed to be Mike Perry versus a Tiago Alvarez.
He could get out of Florida.
Right?
Is that what he said?
He couldn't get out of Florida others?
Is that what happened?
He was stuck in Florida and my parents that we came up early,
so I don't want to hear that shit.
Is that really what happened?
I believe so.
Yeah.
That's terrible.
Do you ever think like when they show the army's walking through like fucking no
man's land,
like who's carrying the fucking food and where?
Where's the water at?
Hey Bro,
you're fucking my high.
When are they taking shit?
I always think that the budget is taking shit.
That's a good point.
Like where,
what kind of sewage system did they,
how bad and just walking across deserts and shot shitting in ancient Rome.
The dude's taking pisses in every scene in the background.
There was a big issue in ancient Rome.
Like they,
people got diseases cause they would shit in the streets.
It's let's talk about that.
Let's bring that in.
Make and more realistic to see more shit.
You're right man.
We'll see food like come on you like explain how these fuckers are eating.
I'd love to see Khaleesi dropping a deuce off the side of that fucking castle.
Have great with that.
That'd be great.
Oh Man.
Maybe the queen maybe like she's shots.
Those shots were those tight shots where they show Khaleesi on the tracking.
I don't remember the Superman TV show.
She's the mother of dragons.
You don't think she knows how to ride a dragon.
I was barely going and she's like holding on.
Somebody's watching you in a Jujitsu match.
Like,
oh,
come on man.
He'd strangle that guy with his leg.
She got to fall off the dragon every now and someone almost want it to a drag.
Oh No,
that was the Harry Potter ride fall off.
She's got to fall off one or two once or twice.
Come on,
man.
She's just like barely grip.
I do hate those shots when they go to her riding the drag it,
it drives me nuts.
I know like some John Wayne shows are both gay for each other cause I thought
that was the most awesome.
I love the show.
Don't get me wrong.
I love it.
What'd she was riding that dragon?
I was standing up cheering because it looks green screen.
I can drag it to look better without it.
Kind of weird.
They're all,
the rulers are women,
but what kind of some feminist shit.
Murder.
Just keep that murder come and I'm happy.
Look,
look,
I'll fake that Louis,
dude.
Come on man.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
Hold it out of that dragon.
Do you know how many spikes would be inside of her pussy?
Right there?
Yeah.
I mean,
where is it safe to stick your box?
You're going to ride that thing between spikes between look at the size of the
spikes.
Yeah.
Look how gross they are.
It's scary and pointy by disease marketing group strength.
Let's be incredible.
It's never show her training does your grip strengths out of this world.
She should have like a rock climbing wall in her castle.
Maybe she takes on the spikes and she puts it down in her pussy,
just lamps,
all of it,
and that's how she goes the whole time.
She just has a spot she could lock in like a ball and socket joint.
I was this another really bad one.
Dragon's way bigger than that.
Like,
yeah,
the dragon's way.
Way bigger than hate the way she's holding it in your [inaudible] spiders and
right when they show the drag and sometimes it looks tremendous.
Huge.
Yeah.
This is episode that's like a Moray Eel,
right?
It might be smaller than it might be younger.
Oh,
that might've been earlier days.
you're right.
You're right.
Again,
it was a big year.
Right?
Okay.
I'm wrong.
Did she used it to kill a bunch of people?
Men.
Some people know some of the last episodes.
Didn't she get out of the chain?
Look how big it was there.
Oh my God.
That's a full grown drag.
Okay.
Hold on a second.
Look at that thing.
Dude.
That's bad.
And moving to the dragon is amazing.
I know that motherfucker CGI,
but when that,
when that White Walker through that spear,
I was like,
when it missed this the first time I felt good.
I know.
I feel like it's alive leave versus got me with the Dragon Johnson versus Borg
again.
Who was a virus though,
right?
They kept him out and he's missed weed a lot.
Oh,
he's Ms. Wade a lot.
Ray Borg is miss wait several times.
And,
uh,
I don't know if he got sick while he was cutting weight,
if other people around him,
but it's just,
you know,
got you can't,
boy,
that's a big opportunity to get sick for and it can happen for sure.
But yeah,
I guess they have to do it again.
They already trained for it.
We'll,
we'll let one of the judges gave it one 18 to one 10 for Canelo Adelaide.
Yeah.
Adelaide Bird Adelai bird did.
That wasn't about her record in the UFC.
Terrible.
One 18 and one 10 for Canelo had they bird.
That's so crazy that a woman or a man,
she's a woman.
She's very nice lady.
Wow.
Isn't that fucking bad?
She's going to get torch for that now.
That's terrible.
Oh,
she stays offline and they have no,
but they have no accountability.
It doesn't matter.
The ties him,
nothing happens to them.
They just keep right on being fucking horrible.
That that's terrible.
Yeah,
it's not good.
I better pissed jeans.
There was one woman who got,
she got in serious trouble for several really bad decisions and she wound up
retiring because it was like people were threatening her life.
Okay.
Mike Perry is a bad motherfucker.
He scary.
It's hard to see that Jake Ellenberger fight if,
I dunno,
a casino owner or whoever is running like the gambling,
the guy at the top of,
he wanted to but just say in a different,
yeah.
If he wanted to rig it,
would you go after?
How would you do go after the judges or the fighter?
I got your explanation.
Two explanation for the game of Thrones thing.
Okay.
Multiple tweets have come that said that they can't swim,
but they can go and water just sink to the bottom.
Oh,
so they sacrificed them.
Yeah,
but who is carrying those chains?
They're not strong enough to carry those strings.
Those chains were gigantic.
Steel is saying,
come on this kid,
I don't want to get hundreds of them.
They just sink,
but wait a,
didn't they drag the dragon and they're strong enough to drag the dragon out.
Why are they strong enough to take the chains in doing a lot of,
it doesn't make any sense.
There's still less holes now or whoever to put them down there is still done.
It makes sense.
He just sacrifice him,
let him stay at the bottom of the water.
They can't get out.
That doesn't make sense.
So they're just walking.
Just walk.
How you can just walk out or it'd be the chain them up.
Even if you had cranes and all this shit,
the chain that thing up,
you'd have to have James Cameron down there with that little submarine trying to
scope it out for awhile.
Tried done that shit up like the titanic.
Keith Peterson,
another excellent refereeing.
That would be way harder.
Titanic.
A dead body.
No,
it wouldn't be hard than the titanic.
Titanic's like miles deep into the water at 13,000 feet down.
Yes.
Okay.